a level that you're never gonna get back
please always push it open to the brain
freeze never expect your respect British
race 50 to be tight 10
[Music]
being the only issue written after 9/11
book three severely shifts the tone of
the Dark Knight strikes again devastated
by the Brainiac ship from last issue
with trouble is's and ruins
clearly inspired by the devastation
after the Twin Towers dr is a lot more
striking in these sections due to its
realistic tone buildings are in ruins
citizens are back and there's a smog of
dust that overlaps everything blocking
out all light heroes search for their
families amongst the rubble and while
it's never initially supposed to be in
this book it actually feels like one of
its strongest moments unfortunately the
death of this lasts about as long as the
Cheeky Girls career and we're quickly
back into the nonsensical do in your
head in new sections that completely
ruined the issue last time carrying over
from the prior issue of the super chicks
a quasi online slash superhero inspired
rock group clearly drawn and over
sexualized they feel like the worst
element of every page they appear on
they will make you wish that a cheeky
girls career had lasted longer that joke
come full circle cuz I'm brilliant
demonstrating how out of touch Frank
Miller is with youth culture these seem
to represent the internet generation
Millennials who go to abstract creations
to tell them what to think and feel
honestly it's absolutely terrible when a
revolt is started at one of their
concerts in order for Batman to gain
troops it's a bad version of the mutant
uprising from The Dark Knight Returns in
the original though that motif was
really well done but here it feels more
annoying than that fat girl who cries at
every house party you go to at first
when you seen a crime you were like
I know the guy who loves kissing someone
else but you know you're a nice person
you come round with but now when you see
a crying it's just like Oh son this
McDonald's is open 24/7 so I don't know
what she's crying about that metaphor
doesn't really work but it shows that
when things keep happening over and over
and slowly getting worse and worse
they're just not as appealing and you
lose interest in them hashtag stop Kony
2012 but I digress
tracking down Superman due to a homing
device at the out in place in this year
Batman confronts the Blue Boy Scout
after revealing that he is a porn for
the government due to canned or being in
Lex's possession The Dark Knight decides
to help him it would be a triumphant
moment but Batman decides to go around
telling everyone that if they want his
help
then they work for him he shouts going
on a crazy power trip like that one guy
at work who gets paid 10 pence more an
hour than you do
so he's technically supervisor and he
just looks down on you and tells you to
clean the toilet because he thinks
you're no good full-time yummy mommy
double scum Laura rebels against this
o'clock informed so that Bruce can speak
to her any way he likes because he's in
charge it's a face palming moment I love
Batman but when he's made out to be an
egomaniac
Justin Bieber type of guy I completely
hate the lad this is worse than when
Bieber said the Anne Frank would have
been one of his fans
yes I'm sure Justin that you would've
loved playing your music in the Attic
it would have been great anyway the
heroes launched their attack on Luthor
and Brainiac at some point Batman has
been captured and he is tortured
repeatedly at the mercy of Lex of course
this is a trap Batman meant to get
caught because bla bla bla bla bla bla
you've heard it a million times wanting
to distract Luthor so that Greenland and
could foil his plans
it seems slightly counterintuitive
Batman whilst cunning isn't stupid and
he would never allow himself to be
beaten so badly just as
see the look on someone's face when he
got the drop on him he's insane
not her mania was analytically the
ending doesn't really work that well in
its moment you know it's alright the
presentations not amazing but it's
actually an all right send off to the
main plot and the book should end at
this point but crazy Frank Miller has
other plans on how he's gonna ruin all
his hard work operating in the
background
Dick Grayson has slowly stalked Carrie
Kelly taking on the appearance of the
Joker he makes his final move in the
Batcave he attacks the girl Wonder and
has her at death's door until the Caped
Crusader turns up whilst in the right
hands this left field twist could have
ended the book on a devastating final
showdown Miller's goofy portrayal of the
regeneration completely mental
invincible Dick Grayson just ruins it he
gets beheaded he captures his head he
sticks it back on his body he loses
limbs and they just grow back and it's
just really goofy what you mean all
comics are goofy Miller never really set
up for this twist at all throughout any
of the previous boots we get no insight
into dick Grayson's motives and it just
seems really unwarranted for the
character never in all of dick Grayson's
history has he been presented as this
crazy unhinged potential villain
so when appears in here it just feels
really underdeveloped it has no reason
to be in the book it's completely
obscure and it's just completely
ridiculous
Bruce beats the Boy Wonder strides the
Batcave and the world returns to normal
it's a bland finish and it's weird that
miller chose the end on this rather than
a slightly better face-off between
Batman and Lex Luthor whilst nowhere
near as bad as the awful second issue
book 3 isn't that much better it
completely under delivers and the fact
that Frank Miller took a year to write
this one issue is completely
unbelievable I have no idea what he was
doing but it certainly wasn't writing or
taking on that's
possessing moments of genius in the 911
sections it's more crushing to see that
these pages get patted out with scantily
clad women spouting utter dribble there
is so much potential here as well but
Miller he just drops the ball completely
and that's why this issue gets a four
out of ten overall the Dark Knight
strikes again was never gonna live up to
its predecessor however one could at
least expect some of the quality from
that groundbreaking title to carry over
side-by-side the groups feel like they
were created by a completely different
team so it's unbelievable that most of
the creative time behind the first one
return here I really don't know what
happened it's clearly drawn really paced
the dialogues terrible and it's just bad
all over possessing more cons than pros
it's really difficult to recommend this
book to anyone other than the most
die-hard fans the first issue is a
really fun ride but none of the good
will I was set up in there carries over
to the closing issues and by the end of
the book you'll just want it to end the
best thing about this book is that in no
way impacts on the Dark Knight Returns
Frank Miller didn't have any element of
that book rat cond and because of it it
doesn't completely ruin your childhood
in the same way that a George Lucas did
I suppose in the same way that George
Lucas never showed young Han Solo in the
prequels running around playing football
with it a little Chewbacca Miller
creates a book that has no consequence
so I suppose that's a good thing of
course it's not called blame Miller for
everything
I'm sure his drug dealer played a big
part too I'm joking I'm joking illegal
purposes I must stress I'm joking but
it's a book that every Batphone should
read at least once to see how bad it is
so overall as a collection the Dark
Knight strikes again gets a four out of
ten so what do you think in the book
there's a lot of people like Grant
Morrison that defend it the first time I
read it I thought I thought it was all
right but on second time no terrible
comment below let me know make sure you
subscribe my channel I've been doing
this series in a build-up to the Dark
Knight 3 the master race and that's the
book I'm gonna be reviewing next it's
just come out so make sure you don't
miss my thoughts on it thanks very much
for checking out my videos take care
poof